welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of The Last
of Us episode 8 we're at Todd's
Steakhouse maybe stick to the salad bar
let's break this down scene by scene for
the details you might have missed the
references to the game the changes from
the game and how chilling this episode
truly is be sure to subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive where next week
I'm gonna be doing a live breakdown of
the finale episode on Sunday night and
of course you can support us by grabbing
some merch at nerdright.shop like this
last with inspired shirt and hey if you
Sunday night HBO Watchers plan to move
on to the final season of succession
after this and you might like to see me
break down those episodes we'd really
appreciate it if you let us know by
liking or replying the pin comment below
okay we open on the blizzardy Lakeside
Resort of Silver Lake where David reads
Revelation 21 from the New Testament and
I saw a new Heaven and a new Earth for
the first Heaven and the first Earth
were passed away Revelation 21 is the an
ultimate chapter to the Bible preceding
revelation 22 as this is the penultimate
episode of the season in this section of
Revelation the author John describes the
resolution to the war between good and
evil when both Heaven and Earth were
remade and God wipes away all suffering
this is what David says Drew him to
Christianity during the apocalypse where
the end of the world has already
happened and these verses in Revelation
describe the Salvation that comes after
those dark times for telling that the
world must be destroyed so that a new
Heaven and new earth can be won of
course we later learned that this is
just some convenient Bible verses that
suits the way David really looks at the
world David's supposed Christianity is
not so pronounced in the game he's not a
preacher that we know of but he does
tell Ellie that he believes all things
happen for a reason and the game does
have that same Banner of when we are in
need he shall provide we don't yet know
here that David is a cannibal bro we
know these could just be grieving
Christians so it makes it harder to
judge the character of David in the
first half of the episode just as it is
in the game when as Ellie you initially
team up with David outside the
steakhouse you can see claw marks on the
wooden planks some bears sniffing the
meat inside perhaps the freezing
temperature reflects another bit of
religious poetry Dante's Inferno in
which the bottom circle of hell is
frozen bird is the furthest away from
God's warmth and David uses the end of
the passage to console the mother and
daughter of the Raider that Joel killed
back on the campus and God will wipe
away all tears from their eyes but there
will be no more death neither sorrow nor
crying neither will there be any more
pain for the former things are passed
away so David's interpretation for them
is that suffering is of the Mortal Earth
but it's not exactly consoling for those
of us still living on this Earth Hannah
asks when they can bury her dad and
David checks him with James before
responding the ground is too cold to dig
will bury your father in the spring yeah
I don't think that's the only reason why
David later says only a few people know
that they've resorted to canvas
ribs on the menu David
is led by Troy Baker who played Joel in
games and hosts the amazing HBO Last of
Us podcast with Craig Mason and Neil
druckman both Troy Baker and Ellie game
actress Ashley Johnson have roles on
this show Johnson will appear next
episode as Anna Ellie's mother while
Merle Dandridge is the one actor on the
show who also played her character
Marlene in the games David asks James
how much they have left and after a
pause he clarifies Venice and elk and
rabbit indicating that they've already
probably begun mixing human meat into
the food supply David's really asking
for a countdown of how long they have
before they have to start killing
current residents and letting everyone
knows that this is what they've been
doing if David acts like he's the second
coming of Jesus James is the analog of
the doubting Thomas who must see to
believe though interestingly it's
Ellie's wrist scarring that opens his
eyes and Joel with the Stab Wound at his
side the two of them together
representing the great Redeemer of this
episode this episode adapts the part of
the game where you play as Ellie at the
Lakeside Resort location as Joel is
recovering from his injury and it
presents a whole new challenge playing
as a character who hasn't had the same
experience as the other protagonist
Ellie uses a bow and arrow in the game
instead of Tommy's rifle with the scope
here and we don't really get to know
David quite as well and they removed the
section from the game where Ellie and
David team up to escape a horde of
infected Ellie first spots a white
rabbit back in episode six I pointed out
this show drawing a comparison between
the White Rabbit that Ellie takes and
Ellie herself a motif continued episode
7 with the White Rabbit in the mall
photo booth and now it definitely seems
intentional this White Rabbit ends up
getting away it's innocent white fur
disappearing in the snow as Ellie
escapes this episode into the White
blizzard you can also draw a connection
to Alice in Wonderland Alice chases a
white rabbit through the portal into
another world as Ellie You could argue
does here with David being the gritting
Cheshire Cat though that cat isn't even
the biggest threat the Queen of Hearts
is and in the show our Queen of Hearts
is that actually we'll get to that in
spoiler Corner as you do in the game
Ellie has to follow the blood trail from
the deer wear that wounded deer
eventually collapses and she finds David
and James there the conversation is
almost word for word except Ellie holds
him up with a gun instead of a bow and
arrow and each other moves I put one
right between your eyes ditto for Buddy
Boy and like Ellie in the game Ellie
ends up being unable to hide her
desperation what do you need we have
boots medicine now Ellie needs
penicillin which is an antibiotic that
ironically is derived from fungus which
the opening scene of the series actually
foreshadowed where do we get penicillin
from fungus by revealing she needs
medicine Ellie outs herself for having
some wounded partner so that from here
forward David definitely knows she is
the girl his group is looking for like
notice he asks that's your dad's gun
you're the one that's sick that's why
you're out here on your own Ellie
smartly unloads both their rifles
showing that she has learned from Joel
from back in episode 3 when he stowed
his gun under the floorboards it's not
always worth it to carry these bulky
guns with you at the end of the day it's
sometimes better to disable these other
guns the ones that you can't carry so
that they can't end up being used
against you while Ellie points a rifle
at them interesting to see her struggle
with the weight of the gun which
apparently Bella Ramsay really did when
they were shooting this those things are
heavy for kids just another tell for
David that she's still getting used to
this gun and it belongs really to
someone else David says that he's a
preacher a preacher who found its
calling after the world ended before
that I was a teacher math taught kids
about your age now saying he's a teacher
is similar to the moment Saving Private
Ryan when Captain Miller finally reveals
that before joining the Army he was a
high school English teacher in fact that
movie came out in 1998 for all we know
David just saw that movie and saw how
quickly it went over the trust of his
group and thought you know what I might
use that it's probably likely that David
isn't telling the truth because later he
says I've always had a violent heart and
I struggled with it for a long time but
then the world ended and I was shown the
truth and so David's backstory is left a
mystery and it probably wasn't good he's
kind of like Heath Ledger's Joker in The
Dark Knight or to borrow from another
survivalist series Lost like Ben Linus
when he claims to be Henry Gale win for
him the shoe was on the other foot and
he was locked to the Kitchen season two
we learned more and more frightening
things about David as this episode goes
but here David says but when the
Pittsburgh QC fell in 17 fireflies and
fedra I left with a few others and
that's how I ended up with our flock so
there's like a
spent in the game that that is where the
Henry and Sam events take place David
also calls his group his flock a common
preacher metaphor which is a bit ironic
since his actor is Scott Shepard who's
in a bunch of things including True
Detective season three I really love
this conversation because in the game
all you really get is David saying
everything happens for a reason and then
segwaying into him saying she and Joel
were the ones they were looking for but
now Ellie and we are lured into this
false sense of security just by David's
affable charm David tells James to give
her the medicine and lets her Escape now
why does he do this this thing a lot of
game players were speculating about and
the actor who played David in the games
Nolan North whom Tommy and I interviewed
on new rockstars a few years back Nolan
North said that David's interest in
Ellie especially when he puts his hand
on hers later wasn't necessarily in the
game overtly sexual but that idea does
start to creep into David's mind as he
considers himself a protector growing a
community he clearly likes to get his
way you know when you put in that
situation maybe the the population is
his group is not as many women and he
wants to repopulate his air and here's
somebody who's clearly a Survivor and by
by the way look at baby Greg Miller
there I love what Greg Tim Colin and
Nick and the rest have built with kind
of funny they got an amazing team over
there but unlike the games we spend a
lot of time with David's community and
we witness their suspicions that they
are eating human flesh what is it
venison it's just so creepy that in
their food prep process the meat has to
come from another room and yes in this
case this meat is probably This Woman's
husband whom Joel killed and David
refused to bury also raw meat and soup
broth you're not gonna Grill it or sear
it first and then deglaze it and then
add the stock I think we need Uncle
Roger in here hi uh now we've all got
bad habits some of us fight our
fingernails I definitely do that some of
us pluck our eyelashes some of us
compulsively click clicky pens
well if you've got a bad habit that
you're trying to kick Doom can help Doom
is a natural diffusive device that uses
plants and Behavioral Science to help
you trade out your negative habit for a
positive one now fume is not a vape
instead of PODS filled with potentially
harmful chemicals fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint
cinnamon or delicious natural flavors
and fumes version 2 model is Snappy and
tactile it's got an adjustable airflow
dial in a magnetic end cap so you always
get something to pitch it with it's like
a little pepper grinder it's satisfying
and look when this showed up in the mail
I didn't really expect much but you know
it's kind of great the flavor is nice
isn't it it gives my hands something to
do besides you know compulsively click
any pen Within Reach nope no no no no
really the easiest way to stop a bad
habit is to switch to a positive one and
fume is designed perfectly to do just
that they have thousands of five star
reviews from people who have used fume
to kick their bad habits to the curb so
head to tryfume.com and use the code new
rockstars to save 10 off when you get
their Journey pack today the journey
pack comes with three unique flavors and
a new version 2 fume to help kick start
your positive habits that's try fum.com
and use the code new rockstars to save
an additional 10 off on your order today
David returns with a deer framed
perfectly under the he shall provide
Banner but there's no joy in the room
since they've all heard now that David
let Ellie get away and Hannah even says
that David should have killed the boat
and David hits her but then helps her
back up yes this guy definitely came
from a violent past and he sits at their
table in the seat of the guy they are
probably now eating and they had injury
to it by saying grace saying she teaches
to know by whom we're fed bless us with
Christ The Living bread yeah Christ The
Living bread definitely a parallel Here
with Jesus at the Last Supper saying
take this all of you and eat it this is
my body this group perversely distorting
that to justify cannibalism while the
residents gobble down there probably man
stew the guy who brought in the meat is
a bit slower to put a chunk of it in his
mouth because he's the one who chopped
the guy up David leads a Hunting Party
through the neighborhood and orders to
leave Ellie alive if we leave her out
here she'll die
yeah maybe that's God's will
[Music]
yeah David is threatened by James
interpreting what God's will is because
David's gatekeeping of God's will is the
Bedrock of his power Ellie lures them
off on Horseback which the game is way
longer and a way more intense Chase
through the cabins but it ends the same
way the horse sadly getting shot and
Ellie falling off it but rather than
having some time to hide in the cabin
and look through a bunch of drawers she
gets taken right away spared by David in
the game Ellie wakes up in the cage to
find a human body already getting
butchered here we get an extra scene
where David has a level of menacing
without being revealed as a fully
fledged cannibal yet the fact that the
cage is here in this room it's
horrifying it means that past prisoners
had a watch as others were being
butchered in front of them knowing that
they would be next meanwhile back in the
house Joel's torture Scene goes down
pretty much exactly as it does in the
game but now we see how he trapped the
two guys in David's group using a
wounded Survivor as a trap just as he
knew this tactic was a trap when they
first drove into KC since he had done
that before this is the darkest we have
seen Joel since he beat the guard to
death outside the Boston qz and Pedro
Pascal plays it not with evil in his
eyes but with just exhaustion as in the
game he puts the bloodied knife in the
guy's mouth to point to the map some
brutal pragmatism because he essentially
made a marker kind of like dollar
sunbridge torturing Harry Potter by
making him bright lines with his own
blood but just as in the game cutscene
it ends with it's okay so I believe him
no that's all right
I believe him no wait now the game
actually shows the pipe hitting the head
thankfully not here because we are not
in Joel's perspective we are in his
victim's perspective so not until David
brings the plate of food does Ellie
notice the ear on the ground she refuses
to eat the food whereas in the game
Ellie trusts that it's deer meat and she
eats some of it before she kicks the
plate but this script in the scene gives
David a lot more of a rationale he says
that this was the last resort to keep
his people from starving and not to
defend cannibalism in really any context
but I do recommend you read up on the
story of the Uruguayan rugby team on
flight 571 in 1972 these were the events
that inspired the movie alive when these
group of survivors crashed in the Andes
mountains and they had a resort to
cannibalism to survive it's an insane
story but these guys had to rationalize
cannibalism as just a group of friends
knowing they wouldn't survive hoping
that their bodies would be used to keep
their friends going perhaps a more apt
historical comparison would be the
Donner Party of 1846 1847 a group of
pioneers who got stuck in the freezing
cold temperatures of the California
Sierra nebadas and some of whom had to
resort to cannibalism of course there's
a whole other thing than what we see
here here I mean we know there are deer
in rabbit in those woods if they just
look hard enough and it's never ever
ever Justified to murder someone and
Jeffrey Dahmer their corpse but David
has an even Wilder rationale he says he
was shown the truth not by God but by
cordyceps what does cordyceps do is it
evil no
it's fruitful it multiplies it feeds and
protects its children and it secures its
future with violence if it must
it loves ah so David really exposes
himself as a false preacher or at least
a guy who distorts the tenets of
Christianity to suit his own perverse
worldview he worships an amoral natural
force saying quote it's fruitful it
multiplies which is a reference to
Genesis 35 11. this episode begins with
Revelation and ends with Genesis in
Genesis God said to Jacob renaming him
Israel be fruitful and multiply a nation
and a company of Nations shall proceed
from you and Kings shall come from your
body another hint at David's true
Jeffrey Epstein goal two seek mates to
produce as many offspring as possible
and David Ends by saying cordyceps loves
a recurring message from Mason and
dreckman the destructive power of love
and how cordyceps with its kissy oral
Transmissions shows how love can be
toxic David places his hand on the bars
we'd make this place perfect
we grow
spread out
and we do whatever we needed for our
people yeah he says grow spread out like
he's describing the fungal outgrowth in
the opening credits Ellie seems to
engage with him for a second but breaks
his finger and tries to steal the keys
this is how the scene ends in the game
both times with David Zane
how did you put it hmm
tiny little pieces how did you put it
huh
tiny pieces
now instead of Ellie seeing the corpse
being butchered in the game this first
glimpse of the corpses here is left for
Joel a few bodies suspended from above
is a lot like the bodies that Joel runs
past in the games later it's just really
freaky to pass these Ellie escapes the
same way by biting David and claiming to
be infected showing them her arm and
using that hesitation to get James in
the neck but one interesting change here
is that the fire in the restaurant is
caused by Ellie throwing a log in the
game a lantern gets knocked over so here
it becomes a hell of Ellie's own making
and David maniacally decides not to
leave fighting David in the game is not
easy you have to sneak up behind him and
be careful not to step on broken plates
because David will hear you and turn
around and you gotta stab him three
times but after the second step David
stops just casually around calling your
name and begins to crouch and sneak
around himself and they pay homage to
that here in the way that Ellie sneaks
it behind David it makes a mistake
oh
Ellie yells and rage before she stabs
him alerting David to turn around and
throw her she can't help herself because
David has just creepily said he's gonna
be her dad and quote teach her to me
this is David admitting his story about
being a teacher was a lie his version of
teaching was probably some kind of
horrible abuse or violence because he
finally reveals while on top of her the
fighting is the part he likes the most
gross the ambiguity that was there in
the game is not ambiguous here David
pins her saying there's no fear in love
this is the ultimate [__] that
proves David has never actually loved
anyone because nothing is scarier than
love as Joel and Ellie know to truly
love something is to feel vulnerable to
feel that you will lose that person or
that something awful might happen to
them so Ellie doesn't just kill David
she absolutely destroys him and
everything he represents and I'm so
grateful this Butchery goes down exactly
as it does in the game and I'm Blown
Away with the intensity that Bella
Ramsay brings
oh
you can hear her voice give out on that
last screen now the game Joel pulls
Ellie off of David but this show lets
Ellie finish until she feels complete
and Joel catches her outside it's okay
baby girl
I got you he calls her baby girl the
first time Joel allows himself to
verbally relate to Ellie as he would his
daughter and notice in the shot of Joel
hugging Ellie his broken watch from
Sarah the one Frozen in time for the
moment of Sarah's death is framed front
and center Joel has now fully mapped his
love for Sarah onto his love for his new
daughter Ellie Ellie has renewed Joel's
purpose of guardianship Joel and Ellie
in this episode not relieved but afraid
because despite what David said there is
fear in love that fear is what makes it
so rewarding when the love is given back
to you because you are just two Panic
Souls clutching each other in the cold
giving each other permission to feel
afraid so you know what
anyone who says there's no fear in love
okay okay
let's quickly check into spoiler Corner
one more episode left folks and I
mentioned the Alice in Wonderland
parallel before despite how evil David
clearly is I think the ultimate Queen of
Hearts of this Wonderland is Marlene
Marlene is the Firefly leader who
manipulated jolinelli to get to the
Saint Mary's Hospital to surgically
sacrifice Ellie for a cure we'll see how
that goes down in next week's finale hey
reminder to subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive and please let us know in
the comments below if you're Sunday
night doing schedule is going to
continue with succession because I would
really love to break that down but if
not enough people are watching it on
this channel we might just talk about in
different ways you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign